[Music]
new at noon hundreds of faith lutheran
students are spreading the spirit of
giving
middle and high schoolers are making
sure local charities have the supplies
they need before easter
next weekend we have hector mejia live
over at faith lutheran on the west side
of the valley with the details on this
hector
well this was a massive operation with
700 students assembling things like this
hygiene kit
and this is just one of several down
there we have a lot more in this day of
giving has
special meaning this year coronavirus
restrictions and concerns canceled
last year's event it's an event that's
been happening here at faith lutheran
for at least
13 years families donate all of these
supplies for local charities we're
talking about hygiene kits
cards with encouraging messages for
nursing homes in the ronald mcdonald
house
blankets plus fruits and vegetables for
a senior apartment complex
you know in a typical year students
would go out into the community but the
pandemic brought the operations
to campus jacob jacob cody the assistant
principal at the middle school believes
this act of kindness
will touch the lives of hundreds of
people
we want to shine a light on that that
you know we can still help
despite the challenges that's that's
that's a great message for them to take
away
some people were just so overwhelmed
with like emotion
because they've never actually gotten
anyone to visit them and help out before
and it just really warmed my heart
so it's all about giving back the event
spanned about three and a half hours
today with students packing writing and
just
helping out and in terms of who is
delivering the items
staff will take care of that task before
they start their holy week spring break
reporting near downtown summerlin hector
mejia 8 news now